[Music]
today's question comes from ellie in
california ellie writes since moving in
with my boyfriend of six years i've
realized that his parents are extremely
toxic
just now realizing that huh several
years of dating you didn't have a clue
exactly
several years ago they lost their
business and home due to money
mismanagement and showed up on his
doorstep asking for a place to stay
over the years he has consistently put
their needs over his own by loaning
money allowing them to live with him for
free and having them work at his
businesses
since they started working for him he
discovered that his mother was writing
payroll checks to his father for work he
never completed ordering parts for their
cars on his business account and my
boyfriend has been sued by a customer
for 15 grand because of his father's
mistakes
they will never take responsibility for
any of this and he will not confront
them i really care about him but
something is telling me to run yeah i
agree run yeah two other people are
telling you to run wow
run
there's three of us now you dave me
everybody run
should i stay and continue to help him
establish boundaries or run as fast i
can run as fast you can you can't solve
that problem period and it's
and and and let me help you with this
too i'm going to be really mean
okay i'm just going to be really blunt
shuckler okay shock alert yeah
just
but i want to warn you ahead of time
before i do it okay so
if after six years of dating him you
didn't realize this
you do not have the relational tools to
enter into this toxic disaster and be of
any good absolutely that's not rude you
are naive yes and that's being kind
blind
intentionally so
yes
yeah
denial is not a river in egypt exactly
oh my gosh um yeah ron you you um
yeah here's the thing this is a
complicated relational psychological
disaster that's going to require
a long time and a lot of professional
help to untwine and you don't want to be
there right
right this is a there's a this this is
this is the worst part of the for better
for worse thing you don't want to be
there
uh because
the problem is not his parents
the problem is his unwillingness to deal
it with it and your blindness
intentional blindness towards the whole
thing now we've got four people in this
four-person story all misbehaving
so including you what does this look
like six years of relationship
plus a home before so you you sit down
and say there's a high probability you
don't make it like 90 something
probability just doesn't make it so do
you sit down and tell him hey
here's the deal you got
or are you just out i i just don't like
you anymore i mean i'm going i mean it's
just i don't like you anymore i'm just
i'm done i don't whatever it is you have
to say i don't know how to break up i
haven't broken up in 40 years
i don't like it anymore i don't like you
anymore i'm
done that makes sense but i mean
i would just say you know what i've come
to realize looking at this that this
thing is too big a mess for me to
participate in and i'm scared
and i've got to leave because i'm scared
yeah which would actually be the truth
if you're smart if you're smart enough
to be scared
it's the truth
and i'm not that this is just grandpa
advice sitting beside the psychologist
okay
um well whatever it is you are not one
of those but the doctor i'm not smart
enough but i i will tell you dr dr
dalony yes it's time to go time to go
and my guess is you know this
you know what you would never she
wouldn't ask i mean
she knows she she mapped it out she
knows yeah this is this is here's the
other way you can ask the question and i
love this one i heard somebody do this
one time and it it made a lot of sense
to me it's
if you had a daughter
and she sat down at your knee
and said the guy i just moved in with
that that did that fill in the blank
what would you tell your daughter yes
run yeah yeah that's what you tell her
and never mistake this
just because it hurts doesn't mean it's
not the right thing and just because
you're going to miss him doesn't mean
it's not the right thing but it's time
to go there's some good parts of this or
you wouldn't have hung around yeah yep
time to go but there are but you didn't
list any of those
geez there's nothing else on the scale
in this email except he's a business
owner he's kind i mean he's probably got
some great quality he's yeah he's an
enabler
like world class apparently